Weininger: Okay,
so let's get started.
Thanks, everyone, for coming.
Um, I'm Nick Weininger.
I'm an engineer on the Google
Custom Search team.
And I'm going to be talking
about advanced Custom Search
configuration.
So I'll start out by giving
a very brief background
on what Custom Search is.
In a nutshell,
the idea of Custom Search
is to bring the quality
and the reliability
and the speed of Google search
results to search boxes on sites
all over the Web.
And what that means to you
as a site owner,
as a webmaster, as a developer,
is that it enables you
to create
a contextual search experience
that's right for you,
your audience.
You can define the scope over
which you want your search box
to search,
whether that be just your site
or a collection of hundreds
or thousands of sites
or small parts of sites
or even a long list
of individual URLs.
You can customize the way
the search works,
the ranking,
and the navigational experience
that your users have.
And you can present results
with a configurable-looking feel
so that you can integrate
that search better
with your site.
And finally you can monetize
that Custom Search
by displaying relevant ads
through AdSense.
And what you may not know
is that Custom Search
can do all of this
in a very sophisticated way
as a developer platform.
You may have seen the Web-based
configurator that we have
for Custom Search engines,
but you may not know
that we also have APIs
that allow you
to programmatically create
Custom Search engines
and to tweak very considerably
both the ranking
and the content
and the appearance
of search results
to create a search experience
that's very tightly integrated
into your site.
And to give you an example,
here is the search
on The New York Times'
website.
It doesn't look immediately
like a Custom Search--
a Google Custom Search.
You couldn't tell immediately,
"Oh, these must be
Google search results."
And that's because The New York
Times has used our APIs
and a good deal
of their own data
to create a search experience
that makes sense
for New York Times users.
So I'm gonna talk
about the key tools
that Custom Search provides
for doing things like that.
I'm gonna describe
the XML format
that defines
a Custom Search engine.
I'm going to talk
about the ways
in which you can
programmatically create CSEs
either by uploading them
to our servers,
or by defining them on the fly
by files that you host
on your servers,
or even by provisioning them
on behalf of others.
And I'm gonna talk about
some of
the more advanced
presentation options
that you have, including some
that we've just released
in the last few weeks,
that allow you to include
rich, structured metadata
in your search results,
to present your search
results
using the new Custom Search
element
that DeWitt mentioned
in his keynote presentation,
and to use server-side XML even
to configure your results
using what's known
as Google Site Search.
So, as always, we should start
with an example.
And, as always, we should
motivate the example
by doing something familiar
and easy.
So I'm going to do something
familiar and easy.
I'm going to create a new
Google Custom Search engine.
Uh, I'm going to call it
the CSE I/O demo.
I'm going to say, man,
this is a cool demo.
I have to decide
just one thing
in the simplest version:
what sites do I want
to search?
Let's say I--for instance,
I want to search
code.google.com.
And I click Next.
And my search engine exists.
I can try out a query...
and get relevant results
from code.google.com.
Now when I finish,
I go to the Web control panel.
And if I click through
on that control panel,
I see a whole bunch
of options,
various tabs,
which I can use
to configure graphically,
wizardly,
various features
of the Custom Search engine.
But this is an advanced custom
search configuration talk,
so I'm going to go straight
to the Advanced tab.
And here I see
a couple of things.
I see stuff
about annotations and context.
You might say, "Hmm, I wonder
what exactly these things are."
Well, I can view this
in the browser.
I'm gonna view the XML
for this context in the browser.
And I have
this annotations thing too.
I'm not quite sure what that is,
so I'm gonna view them both
in the browser.
Now I look at these,
and what do I see?
I see, aha,
I have an ID string
from my Custom Search
engine,
there's a creator ID here.
And I see the title
and the description
that I put in the wizard.
I see this BackgroundLabel thing
that I may not understand
but that I can at least
associate with the idea
of my created
Custom Search engine.
And I see a LookAndFeel
section
that I haven't configured yet
because this is
a very simple,
very easy Custom
Search engine.
And then I go to the
annotations, and I see, aha,
now here I start to see
the sites that I put in.
I have code.google.com.
And it's labeled
with this label
that refers back
to the Custom Search engine ID
that I saw in this context.
And so that's the heart of it.
That's the heart
of what we do
to enable developers
to programmatically create
Custom Search engines.
We simply define
this XML format,
which is just the same
XML format that we use
under the hood,
and it gets modified
when you modify Custom Search
engines in the graphical wizard.
And that Custom Search engine
takes sites
and relates them to a sort
of frame called a context.
And those sites and the context
together define the operation
of your search engine.
So to say in a little more
detail what this means,
the context tells you
about the basic settings
for the Custom Search engine.
It tells you, in particular,
what you can do if you create
refinements for faceted search.
So you may want your search
engine to have options
to drill down into different
parts of your site, for example,
so that your users can navigate
your search
by doing a little browsing
and not just by entering
keywords.
And refinements allow you
to do that.
It also allows you
to do custom things to queries.
For instance, you might have
synonyms, which make sense
only in the context
of your domain of search.
You can define those
in the context.
And so we see an example here
where we have
a refinement label
that's going to correspond
to a refinement link
with the title "Lectures."
I'm sorry.
And those lectures are--
aah--
those lectures are going
to be boosted
with a certain weight.
And they're going to cause
the query to be rewritten
in a certain way.
And now you see
this background label thing.
What that means is simply
the background label
is the label
that defines
the Custom Search engine.
It's the label such that
any annotations, which I define
over any sets of URLs
or URL patterns,
can be hooked in
to the Custom Search engine,
included in its scope
by labeling them
with that link.
And so if I look
at the annotations
for this sample CSE,
I can see, aha,
I've included this--
oops--
I've included a couple
of different URL patterns
and a couple of different ones
of my labels.
So I've hooked them in
to my CSE
in a couple of different ways.
Now that's sort of the classic
Custom Search engine feature.
I want to also call out
a new feature
that we just released
a couple of weeks ago
called Promotions.
And what Promotions are,
are they're completely
custom results.
And you'll see an example
and some screenshots later on.
Which you can define,
simply by saying,
"Okay, for thus
and such a query,
"I want this kind of result
to show.
"I want a result
with this link
"and that URL and this little
text snippet to show.
And, you know, I can even
include a thumbnail image."
And the Promotions,
like everything else
about the CSE,
are defined in XML format.
And it's
a very simple XML format.
Each Promotion says
what queries
it should display on,
what title it should show,
what URL it should show,
and so on.
And if I don't want to interact
with the control panel,
if I don't want to manually
upload and download
these XML files in order
to create or to modify
my Custom Search engine,
all I have to do
is use our RESTful URL patterns
to do these creations
and modifications.
And you can see the full list
of RESTful URL patterns
in the Custom Search engine
developer docs.
But they're pretty simple.
To create a new CSE context,
there's just this URL pattern
with CSE in it,
and you create it
with a CSE ID.
The one other thing
worth mentioning, though,
is that there are a number
of advanced features
which are available,
at least for now,
only in the XML API,
and which you might not notice,
therefore, if you've been
creating Custom Search engine
with the wizard.
I mentioned, one,
at the beginning,
you can create
user-defined synonyms.
Another is that you can boost
and demote different sites
with different weights.
So, suppose you have
a Custom Search engine
that searches
over ten different sites
and you want to say,
"I want to tweak the ranking
as follows.
"I want this site to be
strongly boosted relative
to other results.
And I want this other site
to be mildly demoted
relative to other results
because I think site one
is really good
and site two
is sort of slightly bad.
You can configure that
in the XML
using labels
and annotations.
You can even force results
to come from a certain site
whenever they're available
by specifying what are known
as top N results.
You can affect ranking
in a number of other ways.
For instance, you can bias
results by date.
The New York Times Site Search
actually uses this
to enable you to get
recent news articles.
And, as I said,
there's this Custom Search
developer guide
which documents fully
all of these things
which you can do.
So there's our API.
There's the basis of it.
But now we have this thing
called linked CSEs.
And the reason we created
linked CSEs was as follows:
People said to us,
well, I don't want
to have to interact
with this control panel at all,
and I don't want to have
to interact
with this Google account
at all
that I used to create
my CSE.
Because, in this example,
you'll note I had to go
through a Google account
in order to log
into the control panel
and do the wizard
operations.
I want to be able
to handle a CSE as an object
which is totally independent
from any Google account
membership that I might have.
And the reason is that I want
to define my CSE
on the fly.
I have some data
about what sites are good
and what sites are bad.
I have some data
about how my users want
a search experience
to look.
And that data is changing
all the time.
And I don't want to have to push
an update to Google
every time I change the
definition of my search engine.
I want Google to come to me
and get that definition.
So a linked CSE enables you
to do just that.
The way you define it is
you write out the definition
of a CSE in that same XML format
I just showed you,
you host it at some URL
on your site,
and then in your search box,
you tweak the URL
of search command just a little
to point to that URL.
And the semantics of that
is Google, go get
this search engine
definition file
right when the user
queries it,
parse it out into a definition
of a Custom Search engine,
and give the user a search
on that Custom Search engine
which I've just defined.
And if the contents
of that file changes,
change the search engine
automatically for me.
And the power of this...
is not only that
you can refresh it on demand.
The power of it is,
number one,
that you can make
the contents
of that Custom Search engine
logically dependent
on something else.
The first great use case we had
for this was,
suppose I have a site
that's a directory of links
and I'm constantly
modifying that,
adding sites to
the directory,
deleting them
from the directory.
And I want a search,
which is just, "search all
the sites in this directory."
So the way I want to create
the Custom Search engine
at any one time is I want
to scrape that page,
and I want to take
all the links on it,
and I want to say,
"Oh, okay,
"all the sites
that this links to,
those are the sites that
are included in the search."
So it'll link to CSE.
You can easily do that.
And the other thing
that it empowers you to do
is to create on the fly
very, very large numbers
of different
Custom Search engines
with different annotations
for different sections
of a site,
for different individual pages,
for whatever different
applications you may have.
So let's see a couple
of examples of this.
One of our biggest users
of linked CSEs
is about.com.
About.com is a site
which provides
encyclopedic information
on thousands and thousands
of different topics.
And for each one
of those topics,
they have a sort of subsite.
There's classiccars.about.com.
There's a politics site
at about.com.
There's sites for every special
interest you can think of.
And every one of those needs
its own search experience
because, if you're
on classiccars.about.com
and you go and search
on carburetor
or Corvette for that matter,
you want search results
that reflect your interest
in that particular vertical.
And so what about.com does
is they dynamically create
a Custom Search engine
definition
for every single vertical
that changes
as their vertical changes.
And so here's a screenshot
of custom Web results
on the "Student Travel"
about.com site.
And you'll notice--again I'll
talk more about this later--
that the look and feel
of those results
is very much customized
to the look and feel
of about.com.
And in this case,
they've done that
using server-side XML results
and their own rendering.
Another example:
the Blogger gadget,
which we just--
we just today moved
from draft to live status,
just launched on Blogger today.
And what this is
is a dynamic CSE
for searching your blog
and the context of your blog.
Because, again,
suppose you have a blog
and it links to lots
of other blogs.
It's linked to lots
of other articles
you found interesting,
and you have a blogroll
with perhaps 100 other blogs
that you like.
That is a logical set
of information
over which your blog's readers
should be able to search.
And that information--
that set of information
gets updated all the time.
And you want the search engine
to automatically update
whenever you update
your blog
in a way that changes
that set.
And so Blogger,
using linked CSEs,
provides a feature
that does exactly that.
And to give you an example
of what this looks like
and some of the power
that it uses,
here is the XML source for a
Custom Search engine definition
on one particular blog.
It includes here an URL
of a special format.
Notice the makeannotations
in that URL.
What this is is the tool
that I talked about before.
It goes on a page,
it extracts
all the links from that page,
and it makes annotations
out of all of them
to say, "These are all sites
I want included
in my Custom Search engine."
It includes all of those,
it adds a couple
of actual blogs manually
to the example.
And then it defines
a Custom Search engine,
again just as
in a prior example,
with a title
and a description
and a refinement facet
and some labels.
And that all shows up
within the context
of the blog as
a customized search experience
over that particular blog.
And in this case, we're using
another very powerful,
very configurable
rendering method,
namely the AJAX API,
which I will also talk about.
One other thing I want
to mention
in terms of the APIs
for provisioning
Custom Search engines--
the examples I gave
with the control panel,
uploading and downloading
those XML files,
those are all examples
of creating CSEs
on your own behalf,
on behalf of
your own account.
But we also have an API
that allows you
to programmatically create
a Custom Search engine
on behalf of another.
Now why would you want
to do that?
Well, suppose you have--
you have a business
where you have clients
who host some content
on your site.
And you manage that business,
that client relationship
through Google Apps
for your domain.
So you have programmatically
created Google Apps accounts
in a Google Apps domain
for them.
And you know by virtue
of what content
they have uploaded
what their Custom Search
experience should look like.
And you want to set it up
for them
without requiring them
to do any work.
But you want to set it up
in a way such
that they own it
under their account
so that, if they want
to modify it later, they can.
So this is exactly
what our provisioning API does.
It's part of a suite of tools
that do provisioning things
like this called Google Services
for Websites.
And that suite of tools
includes other things
like submission
of site maps
so that when your clients,
again, upload content
to your site, you can submit
URLs on their behalf
to be indexed by Google.
And here's an example of
one hoster that is using this.
It's a web hosting company
called FatCow,
and it has just a whole suite
of tools
that enable its clients
with a push of the button
to add Site Search
automatically
under their accounts.
So that's how you can create
and tweak the definitions
of a search engine
as a developer.
What can you do to change
the presentation?
Well, again, one very recently
launched thing that I want
to highlight is our support
for structured metadata.
The idea is that if you have
structured date on your page,
then, in a Custom Search engine
that searches over pages
like that,
you may very well want to
include that structured data
in the result block.
And if we parse
and index that metadata,
we can return it to you
in a format that allows you
to do just that:
customize your results
so that they don't look
like plain, vanilla
Google results.
They have the content
that matters to your users,
to your audience,
to your domain.
And we support several different
formats for encoding
that structured data
on your site.
There's a format
called PageMaps.
We support several
popular microformats.
And there's an RDFa parser
coming soon as well.
And if you provide data
on your site
in any of these formats,
we will index it for you,
and, using these XML
and soon the AJAX
presentation methods
that I had mentioned,
you can return it and display it
in your CSE.
And the return format
is extremely simple.
In XML results,
in this example,
it's essentially just a
dictionary of name value pairs.
So your interpretation
of the structured data
is up to you.
You can render it
how you choose.
But we just provide it
to you
as we've seen--
as we've parsed it.
And you take it from there.
Another thing,
great new thing,
launched just today
is the Custom Search
element.
And this allows a combination
of ease of use
and configurability
that I think is really
a great step forward.
It allows you to do
full UI styling with CSS
on the client side.
It includes
special CSE features,
like those refinements
that I talked about,
like those Promotions.
It includes the ability
to monetize
with AdSense ads.
And you can configure Custom
Search element very easily
based on any existing custom
search engine you've created.
Now DeWitt in his keynote
gave an example
of something
that's even easier.
You don't even need
a Custom Search engine set up
to configure an element.
You just copy and paste
a slice of code
onto your page, and we
automatically make one for you.
But if you have created one,
if you have tweaked
and specialized
your Custom Search engine
to be exactly the way you want,
how do you get the element?
Well, if you go back to
this control panel
here...
and you look
at "My search engines,"
you see a handy little link
that says Custom Search
element.
And you click on that.
And it looks just like
the zero configuration example
from this morning,
except in the snippet
of code.
If you look closely,
there is this one parameter,
and that one parameter
is the ID of the Custom Search
engine you've created.
And this will work
with any of the APIs
that I've talked about.
So far it will work
with AP--Custom Search engines
you've programmatically created
on your own behalf
or on other's behalf.
It will work
with linked CSEs.
Any CSE has some ID.
You put that ID
into the code snippet,
you drop the Custom Search
element on your site,
and it works.
And a couple
of screenshots here.
There's a Macworld example
where you've got ads here
with all sorts of refinements
showing up as tabs.
And here is the example,
which showed at the keynote,
with it coexisting
with a number of other elements
on the page.
And note this completely custom
result here,
this promotion
with a custom link
and a custom snippet
and a custom thumbnail icon
all specified by the user.
And finally there is this option
to get XML results.
And the way you get
XML results
is that you use a version
of a product
called Google Site Search.
And this has
a flat fee pricing model
starting at 100 bucks a year
for certain chunks
of queries
and page limits.
And it basically allows you
to take that XML
on the server side and do
whatever you want with it.
You can mash it up
with other content.
You can reorder the results.
You can configure
the look and feel
to match your site.
You can display it
without ads if you choose.
And we have a whole bunch
of sites--again,
eHealthInsurance is an example
of a site
using Google Site Search.
Uh, and they have
a custom result here
and a number of refinements.
So again this is an advanced
user that uses these features
to create a sophisticated
search experience
tailored to
their user alliance.
And, so to summarize,
these are the various features
of the presentation options.
We offer just standard HTML
rendered for you
displayed in a separate page
or an iframe
where you can do
a Custom Search element,
or with the Google Site Search
product
you can get XML results.
And for the next part
of this presentation,
I'd like to invite
up on stage,
um, a couple of folks
from Adobe,
one of our largest
Site Search partners,
which has used Site Search
in some very innovative ways
to serve their customers,
and they'll talk a little bit
about how they do that.
Thanks a lot, Nick.
Nichoson:
My name is Mark Nichoson.
I'm a product manager
for Community Help
at Adobe Systems.
I'm just--
being a product manager
in a room full of developers,
I'm gonna be really brief
and invite my colleague
in just a moment,
Joel Brandt,
who's gonna talk
about some of the more exciting
work that we're doing,
but Nick in particular
wanted me to talk a little bit
about our use case
of the CSE,
so we've been using
Custom Search as part
of a service called
Community Help
for about a year now.
Um, and it's something
that we launched
with the last round
of Creative Suite 4.
Um, our use case
is a little bit unique
in that one of the things that
we've been really trying to do
over the last year and a half,
two years,
is really embrace some of
the new content community models
that have been enabled,
you know, via Web 2.0
and find out how to best
leverage those models
within the context of Help
and Support with our products.
So one of the great things
about Adobe
is that our customers
are just incredibly passionate,
so people love Photoshop,
they love blogging
about Photoshop,
they love writing tips
about Photoshop.
Um, and they love helping
each other.
That's very visible
to anyone
who's visited our product
forums, things like that.
Um, or anybody who's been a part
of our developer community.
And so really, for us,
the real challenge
that we were trying to solve
was how do we bring
all this great wealth
of community content--
I call it, sort of,
the community ecosystem--
how do we bring that all
directly
into the user experience
when somebody's actually working
in one of our applications
and has a problem?
So how do we, you know--
it's a tremendous
aggregation problem really.
And at the end of the day,
working with Google--
um, you know, Search became
a really natural,
really simple metaphor
for solving that entire problem.
So we partnered with Google
about a year ago.
And we use, you know,
a lot of the features
that we use are the ones
that Nick described.
So we actually
use the XML results.
For us, that's incredibly
important because, you know,
Adobe, you know, the brand
and the experience
of our products
is very, very important
to our users,
so being able to maintain
that consistent
brand experience
when somebody's working directly
inside Photoshop
and then taking them to,
you know, a branded experience,
maintaining that
is incredibly important.
We also really appreciate
that it was a hosted solution,
that it wasn't anything
that we were gonna have
to really, you know,
keep up with,
from a development
perspective.
Let's let Google do
all the heavy lifting.
Um, and for us, that was--
that was really important.
So one of the key things
that we did
with Custom Search
in the CS4 timeframe
was we actually integrated it in
with the products.
So if you open up
Dreamweaver CS4
or Illustrator CS4
right now,
you'll find actually
a little search widget
that's embedded
in the application itself.
Um, and what that search widget
is doing
is it's going out and sending,
via an API,
calls for a Custom Search
engine
and bringing those community
results directly back into--
into that--
into the user experience.
So right now we have
about 2,400 community URLs
included in
our Custom Search engine.
This has been a very successful
service for our customers.
We're doing some data analysis
on that right now.
I'm sure Nick and Rajat would be
very curious to see the data,
and I'll definitely
be sharing it with them
as soon as possible.
And, you know, that data's
definitely gonna be influencing
how we are thinking about
Custom Search going forward.
So right now, as I said,
if you open up
any creative Suite 4 product,
if you are a developer working
with Flex or AIR or ColdFusion,
uh, you'll come across
some of
these Community Help
search results.
So I'm gonna invite up Joel
Brandt, who's gonna tell you
about some
of the exciting things
that his team's
been working on
and some of the success
that they've been building upon
with the Custom Search
engine.
Brandt: Thanks, Mark.
Uh, so I'm Joel Brandt,
I'm a researcher at Adobe
and also a PhD candidate
at Stanford.
And I want to talk briefly about
another tool we're building
called Blueprint.
And if you like
what you see in this talk,
you can come visit us
at the Developer Sandbox
and take it for a spin.
So the work we're doing
right now is motivated
by a really simple
observation.
Programmers use the Web.
A lot.
In fact,
we ran a recent study,
and in this study we were
looking at how people learn
to use new libraries.
In that study,
over 33% of the code
these people produced
over several months
was produced--
was lines of code
that were taken from the Web
and modified.
So what's really crazy
about that
is that, despite the fact
that programming languages
are designed to be read
by computers
and our development tools
don't know anything
about the fact that,
you know,
we're using the Web to produce
this code.
And our Web browsers
and search engines
don't know anything about the
rest of the code we've written.
Our editor simply thinks
we're typing
everything we write.
So our idea was can we leverage
Google Custom Search
to bring search inside
the development environment?
So Blueprint is a tool
that explores this idea.
And let me give you
a quick demo of that,
and then we can talk
about how it works.
So in Blueprint--
Blueprint is built as a plug-in
for Adobe's Flex Builder, which
is a development environment
for Flex and Flash
applications.
A lot of times,
programmers are in situations
where, here they have some code
that they want to visualize.
In this case, they want
to put it in a chart.
And creating a chart's
very easy to do,
but it takes about 20 lines
of code,
and it's probably not code
you can write from scratch.
So it'd be great
if you could initiate a search
for example code
that would help you learn
how to do that right from
your development environment.
In fact, that's
what Blueprint allows you to do.
You can hit a quick hot key
to bring up a search box
that's sort of
like AutoComplete.
You can type natural language
into this,
something like barchart,
and that presents you
with results that present
example code first.
So this is an example of us
customizing the search results.
Here we present the example code
immediately,
and you can scroll through this
to see running examples
of that code.
Once you select some code
you like,
uh, perhaps after performing
another search,
you can immediately put
that code
into your development
environment.
A few modifications
of that code
and very quickly you have
something up and running.
So how is Blueprint built?
As I mentioned,
we're leveraging
the Google Custom Search
suite of tools.
But in order
to do that custom work
of presenting examples
themselves
rather than the entirety
of the web pages,
we have to build on top
of Google Custom Search.
So there's three components
in what you saw here today.
There's the Blueprint client,
which is what lives
inside Flex Builder.
There's the Blueprint server,
which sits
on Adobe's infrastructure.
It sits on top of the Google
Custom Search engine.
When a user makes a query,
we gather contextual
information
from their programming
environment,
so the versions of frameworks
they're using,
things that are in scope
and so forth,
and send that along
with the query.
Our server uses
that information
to augment the query
and produce a better query
to send off to Google.
We then send that search
off to Google
and get back a set of results.
We parse these pages
that come back to Google
for the actual examples
in running code.
And then we send those back
to the user.
So this is all well and good.
Now you know how it works.
But is this actually effective?
So we ran a laboratory study
to get at answering
this question,
see if we were really benefiting
by sitting on top
of Google Custom Search
results
and providing this tool
to users.
So first we found
that participants found code
twice as fast,
which is a big step
in producing the code quickly.
In fact, if you look at the
ranking of all 20 participants,
you see that the majority
of those,
here presented in blue boxes,
that were using Blueprint
fell toward the fast end
of the spectrum.
But even more importantly
than writing the code quickly,
they wrote significantly
better code.
And this is even more
striking.
You see almost all of the people
who used Blueprint
were on the side where
they produced the best code.
We think this is probably
because we are able
to present the search results
in a very customized manner
that helps evaluate code
quickly.
So in one of the tasks,
the best results didn't have
a very good standard
Google results snippet,
and so they normally wouldn't
click on that page,
but because we were extracting
the code specifically
and they were to evaluate
that code
rather than the English
on the page,
they were able to select
a great example
and get a really good result.
So we just launched Blueprint
as a plug-in
that you can download for free
at labs.adobe.com today.
So I'd love it if you could
all take a look at that
if you do Flex development.
And with that, I'll pass things
back to Nick to complete.
Thanks a lot.
[applause]
Weininger: Thank you, Mark.
Thank you, Joel.
Um, I don't have a lot more
to say after that
other than that's a really great
and innovative use
of search in a context
where I would never have thought
it could be used.
Um, I want to call out
one thing
that's something you might
think about as developers.
I think the feature
of contextually rewriting
the query based on what they
know about the user's context,
that they're searching
within a particular product
and so forth,
is really powerful.
We provide a number of hooks
to allow you to do this.
And I think you should consider,
as search designers,
the extent to which your users
can benefit from this
'cause it's a really great thing
to do.
And Adobe is an example
of one of
our largest partners,
but we have a very,
very long list of partners.
In fact, we recently passed--
not so recently any more--
passed quite a while ago
a million registered CSEs.
And we're still growing fast.
And we'd love to have
your Custom Searches
hosted on our platform.
And so that users
all across the Web
can get better search.
So thank you,
and I'll take questions.
Any questions?
Yes.
man: So--
[feedback]
Weininger: Whoo.
man: Wow.
Weininger: You happen
to be mic'd?
man: Should still be mic'd.
So let's say I've got
a set of--
a website
that I don't want indexed
in the regular,
standard Google results.
Weininger: Right.
man: So I have, let's say,
a robots.txt file
that says, "Don't index this,
Google."
Is that still something
that I can use
in Google Custom Search
engines
or Google Site Search?
Weininger: So currently
the answer to that is no
because we--the Custom Search
index follows--
it follows the same crawling
rules and, well, ultimately,
mostly, Custom Search index
just is the Google Search index.
We do have some extensions
to it.
As you know,
you can submit site maps
to be indexed
in a special CSE index n-tier.
But even that index respects
the same robots.txt crawling
rules as any other Google crawl.
So--but it's a good question.
We should think
about whether to do that.
man: You mentioned something
about AJAX APIs...
Weininger: Mm-hmm.
man: And I didn't see it.
Weininger: Oh, so the Custom
Search element that I discussed
is built on
the AJAX Search API,
and the full power
of the underlying Search API
is available in that element.
That's what AJAX refers to.
man: If I have
a custom content site,
and it gets crawled by Google
every two or three days...
Weininger: Sure.
man: And right now I have
my own Custom Search.
If I want to use your engine,
can your content somehow be
indexed more frequently?
Or how do you approach that?
Weininger: Yes, in fact,
we have a feature design
to help you do just that.
Um, it is called
On-Demand Indexing.
And the way that it works
is you--
if you've submitted site maps
already to Webmaster Tools,
you can pick one of
those site maps as containing
your freshest
and highest priority pages.
And you can actually go and
click where there's also an API
that you can issue a request to
that says index this now.
And we will, again, use our
special Custom Search index
and capabilities to go out
and recrawl those pages
and index them again
within 24 hours.
So you can at least get
that increase
in speed and freshness.
man: So Google keeps almost
everything that's crawled,
but occasionally we know
that stuff falls out
of the Google index.
If we have a CSE,
is there anything that says
that our content
that's in the CSE
will be somehow more sticky?
Weininger: Well, again,
this is what
our Custom Search-specific
indexing capabilities
are designed for.
Um, you can submit--
you submit site maps
to Webmaster Tools,
and we either can implicitly,
automatically learn that
those site maps are included
in your CSE, or in
the On-Demand Indexing feature
I described, you can actually,
explicitly tell us
this site map is for my CSE.
And, you know, when we go and do
those on-demand crawls,
those pages will be,
as you say, sticky.
man: And you said
for the XML results,
the price is starting
at $100?
Weininger: Yes.
man: Um, okay.
Then what?
What's the real range?
Weininger: Okay.
So there are a number
of different pricing tiers
based on two factors.
Number one is the number
of pages that you want
to include
in your Custom Search.
And number two is the number
of queries you want per year.
I think the, sort of,
online tiers
go up to about
$2,000 something,
$2,250 a year, which
gives you up to 100,000 pages
and a 1/2 million queries
a year.
Um, the $100-a-year level
gives you,
I think, 1,000 pages and
a 1/4 million queries a year.
And if you have needs
for Site Search
over a really large corpus
or with
a really high traffic level,
then you can contact one
of our sales representatives.
man: I have a question about--
so I think it's great
that you guys are, like,
indexing the microformat
stuff.
Is there a way you can search
against that?
You know, so if you wanted to,
say, put an author,
you know, as a micro--
you know, as a vCard
or an hCard, as they call it,
I guess,
in the microformat scene.
Is there a way you can sort of
search against that?
Weininger: You mean to filter
the search
or to re-rank the search
based on structured data?
man: Yeah, like, so if I wanted
to, say, you know,
search a website
full of documents,
and I just want to search
by author or something.
Weininger:
That's a very good question.
The answer is "Stay tuned.
We're working on it."
Um, so actually
our product manager is here
and is more qualified
to speak to that than I am.
Mukherjee: I don't know
about more qualified,
but I can take a shot at it.
Uh, so in terms
of terms of service,
so as I said--
as Nick mentioned,
there are various offerings.
There's the online offering
where you basically
get the vanilla product,
and you're off and running.
We also announced elements
today,
so that's another kind of
turn-key kind of thing,
which is you take it and go.
The terms of service,
they are typically, you know,
what the online terms
of service are.
When you license Site Search
or if you're a direct partner
and, you know,
you're actually driving
a huge amount of traffic,
there are typically special
relationships we have
with our partners.
And in some of those cases,
there are special sort
of agreements that we have
with those partners.
At that point,
there's a lot more flexibility.
So, for example, Site Search
customers like Adobe,
you know, they have special,
sort of, contracts with--
with Google, and we have
a lot more, sort of, control.
In general,
Site Search customers
have a lot more
branding controls
because that's one
of the requirements
of the enterprise, sort of,
offering.
But in general, the online,
sort of, customers go
with the online terms
of service,
which we typically don't,
kind of, negotiate
on a one-by-one basis.
So does that answer
your question?
man: Yes, it does.
Mukherjee: Absolutely.
So on the online version,
you need to use
the Custom Search branding,
and there are various options
there as well.
So you can actually choose
the one that works for you.
You can still customize it
in terms of look and feel
and colors and stuff like that
so it doesn't kind of--
so it matches up
with the rest of your site.
But you absolutely need to use
the Custom Search branding.
And typically online customers
use ads as well.
So monetization with ads
is on by default.
And Site Search customers
have the option
to turn off ads.
Weininger: Hi.
man: I was wondering
if you could speak to--
we'd all love to have
all of our content
indexed by Google,
but in those cases
where we can't
or it isn't indexed,
the search appliance
and the integration
between Custom Search
and the search appliances,
if there's any pending,
future thing
where you can have results
coming from the search appliance
that show up in the Custom
Search results as well?
Weininger:
That's an interesting--
that's an interesting
question.
Um, we understand
that, yes,
there are cases
where you don't have
all of your content indexed
by Google.
Um, we have,
as I've mentioned
for a couple
of prior questioners,
we have these features
based on, you know,
CSE associations with site maps
and On-Demand Indexing
designed to improve coverage
of your content
specifically for customers
of Custom Search engine.
Um, I recommend
that you try those
and see if they do
what you need.
If even those don't do
what you need,
please let us know why.
Because we want to make sure
that, wherever possible,
we do manage to get in
all the content
in any given Custom Search
engine.
And, as to your specific
question of search appliance
and Custom Search engine
integration,
we don't have anything
like that now,
but it's an interesting
possibility.
Oh, ah, yes.
Rajat has an additional comment
on this.
Mukherjee: So in terms
of actually getting
Custom Search results
into your appliance
in the intranet,
I think there have been
some widgets
and federated capabilities
that have been built
so that if you, for example,
are using the appliance
in your intranet
and you also have
a Custom Search engine
for your website,
you are able to basically pull
those results in
because they use
the standard XML formats
that the appliance uses
and honors,
so you can actually
have federation
where you can actually bring
those external results
into your intranet.
But the reverse
is typically not done.
Weininger: Let me get that.
Thanks--thank Rajat
for the reminder.
If you're familiar with
the appliance in particular,
there's this API called
the Enterprise OneBox API
that allows you to integrate
many other kinds of content
into Google Search Appliance
Search results.
And one of the clients
that you could integrate into
would be Custom Search
results.
So you could do
the combination
that you're looking for
that way.
Correct.
Oh, so just to say again,
there's an API
at the appliance level
that would allow you
to take
appliance-rendered search
results and include in those
results from a hosted-by-Google
Custom Search engine.
But we don't have
the capability yet
to go the other way,
to have a Custom Search engine's
hosted results
include results from a GSA.
Other questions?
Well, okay.
If there are
no other questions,
then thank you all very much
for coming.
[applause]